trying to summarize what i learned in a
year is hard
[Music]
what's going on everyone uh happy
tuesday
um i hope you're having a phenomenal day
whatever day it is that you're listening
to this um i had a lot of requests
um from instagram and dms and
thank you for those uh for the 2020
lessons and failures uh so this will be
a sequel to my 2019
lessons and failures which if you
haven't listened to that one i think uh
my my year-long recaps are i think some
of my better ones
um but it's obviously up to you so this
one will probably a little longer than
what you're used to
and that's because trying to summarize
what i learned in a year is hard
in one episode and so for those who
don't know
i i keep an ongoing email thread to
myself
consistently consolidating 20 20
lessons and failures so you can well
maybe you can't see it on the thing but
it's there all right and so i have this
big thread
that i just continue to email myself
whenever i
feel like i learn a lesson and so i will
do my very best
to tell you each of the lessons that i
learned
and how i learned it and 2020 was a
was a packed year of lessons for me and
so
uh where to start um
where okay well
from the 500 you know million dollar
mastermind i learned a lot
um from there i really learned about
scale um and seeing the people that were
doing more than me
all were going after bigger markets so
there's really two options for me to do
that within the context of gym launch
one is
go after find alternative and
additional channels to grow the business
because you know it's not like we've
sold 100 of gyms and so that means that
i have to find
new ways to reach them so if my
traditional advertising methods
um obviously you know you can exhaust a
platform uh especially if there's a
niche
it's usually much bigger than you think
it is but
you may you may not have reached every
single person on that platform but you
may have reached every person that you
could reach on that platform
profitably um so that's kind of the the
differentiation
and so uh for me seeing all these people
who are doing more than me and i was you
know providing value to them in a lot of
ways
and i it's always like it's been a
consistent effort of mine
to try and understand if there's anyone
who makes more money than me
what it is that they have or what it is
that i have that they do not have
because sometimes the question is not
this is an interesting one for you that
i've learned also is
it's not always good to say uh what does
this person have that i don't
sometimes it's what do they lack that i
have and i think oftentimes it's more
frequently the case which is why it's
always backwards which is why i think
the learning process is interesting
and so you know champions beat normal
people
at their endeavor not because they have
something the other person doesn't but
because they lack the ability to stop
working they
black the off switch and so i think
sometimes not only thinking what do they
have
but what do i have that's limiting me
rather than what do they have that's
giving
them an advantage over me so first off
just even switching my thought process
to thinking that way has been a lesson
of 2020
um for me from an entrepreneurial
perspective um
before i go any further i'll just say
this so that you know i'm supposed to
keep things interesting
during these podcasts so we hit our 100
million dollar
um amount in 2020 which is kind of weird
so just to
to clarify this for anyone uh the
reasons i didn't put it on this award
yet is because uh
i'm not very handy with things and i'll
probably mess it up so i'll have someone
else do it
um but just for transparency that means
i've done 100 million dollars in total
sales in the last three and a half years
um and so we did we did 30 we did 28
million
we did seven million in in in 2016
we did 28 million in 2017 in 20
2018. we did 37 million
in 2019 and uh in 2020 i think we
finished at 31.
uh we're still getting the final books
for this year um
but yeah so that was you know that's the
that's the deal that's how we we hit 100
million so it's not like i did 100
million in 2020 just for full
transparency because
i think some people thought that that's
not what it was um
but i made a podcast about how uh
i i've been stuck at 30ish million for
three years and i finally figured out
what i need to do to fix it and um
among those is hiring really good talent
uh that is one um another one
and that sounds like so like duh alex
but i feel like it's so many times the
lessons that i learn or not like
nothing's novel
like nothing's novel it's just at what
point does we call them singed moments
but at what point does something that
you've heard your whole life become real
for you
you know um for some of us it's like be
kind to others it's something you hear
your whole life but maybe
some moment or some event triggers that
for you and you're like maybe i should
be kind to people and then you start
changing the way you live
and so for me uh you know i've always
heard niche down i think it's important
to niche
especially when you're starting but you
will eventually be constrained by that
niche
uh but that being said if you're like i
get this one all the time
from our clients which is like man i got
my niche is too small
and like homies doing like 500 grand a
year i'm like
your niche is a six billion dollar
industry and you think that you doing
half a million dollars a year has
somehow tapped that niche
you just have such a poor business model
that your lifetime value of a customer
is so low that you can only profitably
reach
a half i mean like a quarter of a
quarter of a quarter of a percent of
your market
so it's really important to delineate
between am i
capping my niche or are the economics
behind my business model
stifling my ability to scale and grow
profitably
i think those are two very different
things and everyone just likes to say
likes to point outwardly because it's
easier to say oh my niche is small
rather than thing saying no my my
business model sucks and i have no way
of profitably reaching these people
which either means you need to fix your
business model or you need to find
alternative or additional acquisition
channels
um and so for us i think we have a we
have a i don't know of a lot of
businesses that have higher ltv from
from you know micro gym owners than us
and that's candidly because we provide
more value than
everyone else does in the marketplace
that is why you get rewarded and so
uh i mean i always am trying to expand
ltv
provide more value find ways that we can
you know solve problems
and i i will always continue to do that
but given the numbers that we have
um the la one of the lessons of 2020 is
expanding additional acquisition
channels and so we were able to build an
outbound acquisition channel in 2020 so
that was um
uh really cool and the additional part
of what made that cool for me was that i
actually had someone else own the entire
process and end so when i talk about
hiring high level talent it's really for
me transitioning from the what to the
who
and you've probably heard that before
but on some level it became real for me
and the obsessive nature of the
entrepreneur of wanting to learn how to
do everything is
absolutely required in the beginning but
as you scale up it is more about finding
the who
but the thing is is that in the
beginning you think too soon you need to
find the who and in reality you still
need to learn the things
that make the business work and so i
think that's why context and timing is
so hard with these things because we
have to find like when i'm trying to
give you know advice it's
you know you have to take it within like
your current paradigm and i understand
that that's difficult and that's why
sometimes it's hard listening to
billionaires because it's like
their paradigm of of what's happening
what is
what are the successful actions for them
right now in their in their current
chapter
is different than somebody who's at zero
or at a hundred thousand dollars a year
and so i'm going to try and cater this
as broadly as i can with as much you
know contextual points
as possible so uh
number one adding additional channels
number two focusing on who not what and
specifically high value who
and my picker my ability to judge
the quality of talent has increased um i
think
i've gotten better at it i was not
nearly as good at it years ago and i
don't know how you learned that without
experience
so that is that is something
try and find people with pre-loaded
solutions so as a as a caveat to that
that's one of my lessons which is like
i've i've now found people who come
pre-loaded with solutions they come
batteries included
you know i'm like hey here's my problem
i can point them at it and they're like
oh
this is all the things we need to do
because i've already done this three
times i'm like
got it yes please go do that and you
know as
a as a correlator to that my role within
the company i would say in 2020
transitioned from being
a ceo to being
investor slash owner or slash
stakeholder shareholder whatever way you
want to say it but really
i would say for the first time in 2020 i
really transitioned to being above the
business
um not in like a weird airing away just
like not truly being out of it and so
i think there's definitely levels to
being out of it you know first you're
uh you own your own job right you're
self-employed and that's just you doing
things
for other people for money you just
someone else is paying you and you're
doing stuff
you know above that you start becoming a
manager and managing other people right
and then above that you become a leader
and then above that
in my opinion you become an executive
right which is like leading
organizational change in departmental
change around
objectives that are going to protect the
business or grow the business right
and i think the level above that is
where i i feel like
this year i was able to get to i could
be wrong
we'll find out in 2021 lessons and
failures
uh but but i've right now
i'm not i don't actually do anything um
in the business besides meet with
two leaders a week um
and really advise on the ways
that we can strategically improve the
business and provide more value
and so that's really the majority of my
time is like
looking at the overall marketplace and
thinking like how can we provide more
value in a strategic way to
everyone right and what are of the many
ways what is the one thing that we're
going to focus on
and so i think 2020 was also a really uh
humbling year for me
because uh we got to refocus on
the few things that provide the most
value and so for us it's
we need to get jim's leads because
that's what everyone wants
uh we need to make gyms more money
because that's what everyone wants and
that's about it you know pretty much any
other you know endeavors that are not
focused on those things
uh are kind of a waste uh as much as you
know people
may need to have better retention
tactics better
um you know better profit margins and we
talk a lot about that whenever we do
talk about that we lose people who lose
interest because entrepreneurials
most entrepreneurs that i serve um only
think about revenue right the only thing
about growth
rather than what am i taking home you
know how much risk am i exposed to that
kind of stuff and i think that just
comes with time
but i will practice what i preach and
not
sell what i want to sell i will sell
what they want to buy and so that is uh
how
you know we've we've cut a ton of excess
out in 2020
um in the business and so uh really
focusing on a handful of key priorities
um
has been really useful and interestingly
i think the business has actually
improved since i've moved further away
from it because i tend to break things a
lot because i want to fix it till it's
broken if you know what i mean
and so giving our leadership space to
just
transact you know run the business has
been
um really valuable and i think it's
actually been i think it's been better
for the business overall
so uh those are some of uh my my initial
list i've got a whole bunch so i'm just
to keep going through this
so one of the next ones was um i was
talking to
brooke castillo she is an amazing
business a good friend of mine
if you've heard of her life coach school
podcast check her out she's an amazing
pie she's a huge following
um and she didn't say this directly but
like the the term that came in my mind
was
scale skill zero and simple scales and
or zero scales
um i'll have to come up with something
catchy for that but basically
the reason that i had to be get into the
you know quote in
investor or owner type role i believe
is because if i am involved in any
really day-to-day activity
i will become the bottleneck right and
it's not a bottleneck of communication
which is what happens when you are the
manager
as a bottleneck but as as as somebody
who even
provides value in any way if it requires
you
to be there to provide the value then as
soon as the team grows outside of you
providing that value if it cannot grow
without you providing whatever that
value is
then it will stop there and so i think
that's 2020 was really my transition of
of moving above that and so i think that
was kind of the win for the year
um and so that was kind of one of the
lessons that i learned is is you have to
scale zero like i have to get myself to
doing
nothing and still have the company
make money and grow and be profitable
etc
in order for us to be able to grow
beyond where we're at and i think that's
much easier said than done
especially because a lot of companies
start because the entrepreneur is
skilled in a certain way
or has a variety of skills which is
usually what happens we have a stack of
skills which is why
you know why we start growing um and
then somehow you have to
in the beginning extricably you know or
intrinsically link yourself to every
aspect of the business is what makes it
grow
and then piece by piece peel off each of
these skills and traits and
and things that you don't even know you
do in the business to keep it moving
and that's taken time and it's and it's
taken trial and error and it's been
difficult but ultimately rewarding um
because now
right now it's i would say like one day
a week is focused on all my leadership
meetings um
and that's it and then beyond that it's
just strategic insight uh on monthly
and quarterly's so um that's given me a
lot more time to really focus on the
industry and how we can
and help overall rather than being kind
of like in the in the tactics
um next one um
i have this belief and it just continues
to be reinforced that
see if you can just keep growing and not
hire people um
we have had uh i mean all you gotta do
is look at our
our atrocious glass door reviews um
which suck
uh to know that like we have we hire
fast
um we've had a tendency to hire fast and
fire fast so we
have followed that mantra um
but i and the thing is is part of the
difficulty of having a business that
that grows quickly is um or has any
level of volatility month to month
is that you have these waxing and waning
demands for
labor right and so it's like you need
five people and then the next month you
don't need the five people anymore and
uh you know i'm not saying we hire five
people and then let them go it's more
that like
that consistent variability uh can be
annoying from uh from a payroll and
labor standpoint
and what's unfortunately happened many
many times
is we'll bring people on
um we will solve the problem
and then they won't and it really should
be like you know for defined periods of
time
you know like project based and whatnot
um the problem will be solved
and after we let the people go the
business grows more
and that's kind of weird and backwards
for me as an entrepreneur
and so i'm going to just try and make
sense of it out loud with you
um but
i i kind of have this belief that only
one out of five employees in a company
is providing value like i i actually
like kind of believe that
uh kind of the 80 20 people are fractal
um i just can't like i just the amount
of times that we've literally gotten rid
of like a department
because it's just like we we created a
department for example to solve a
problem
let's say it was churn and provide value
in all these ways to solve churn
and then after scaling that after six
months realizing that churn is
completely unaffected and we just took
20 more employees on and then having
just be like
well guys you didn't solve the problem
and as much as you're doing stuff
it doesn't is not doing anything right
and so then we have to you know let
people go because it is a business
and um and then and and then just
realizing that the business
literally doesn't change at all like
revenue doesn't change return doesn't
change
profit doesn't change well profit goes
up and that's it and it's just like
it's mind-blowing to me it's like there
are so many people especially as your
organization grows that you're like
this person was totally unnecessary and
that's crazy because from the employee
perspective it's like
how can you do that and i understand
that perspective but on the flip side as
the owner you're like
man this this person was 90 000 a year
like
people are afraid of signing up for a
mastermind and yet we'll
hire an employee for 50 000 a year
without even thinking about it
and it's just like which of these things
is providing more value you know what i
mean and so that's that's something
that's been like
mind-blowing to me is is seeing a
company grow
after shrinking it's like it's crazy and
it's happened
so many times and it happened twice in
2020
for us where i would get rid of a key
team or a key you know series of
individuals who were doing a role that
we
we were tracking metrics on and we kind
of implemented it into
to provide a solution and then it then
disappeared right and
because the solution like it did not
solve the problem and therefore was not
providing the value that it was supposed
to
and so people were essentially cutting
grass with scissors which doesn't
they're doing stuff but it doesn't mean
it's being valuable right
and so um i am now really trying to
add the constraints to i want to see if
we can grow
with no people like how can we look at
berkshire hathaway right how can we look
at warren buffett who has 19 employees
and
runs a gigantor you know company
how can we find fewer
smarter people that are pre-loaded with
solutions like i said earlier but it's
like i'm just trying to hit this in
multiple ways because it's
it's really ingrained in me this year
how important having an a player is
compare like one a player
literally does more work than 5b players
it's crazy like
most people actually do nothing like
it's it's it's crazy like most people
don't do anything and and and that's why
they can't progress i mean like
as a tangential side story you know i i
there's a guy that i've seen in a
mastermind
this is an entrepreneur right and
he's uh you know he's like hey you know
and this is three years ago when i met
him
he was like yeah i'm going to start
running facebook ads and i was like
awesome
fantastic like that's a great idea and
because his biggest issue was that he
couldn't get legion right
sorted and i saw him at an event three
years later
and i was like hey man how's it going
you know how's the business whatever
and uh he was like yeah just you know
we're gonna start we're gonna we're
definitely gonna start facebook ads soon
and i was just like bro it's been three
years
like what are you doing you're like what
are you like what are you doing
you know what i mean like it just you
know what i mean there's different ver
it's different for me if someone's like
trying to figure out what the obstacle
is
versus knowing what the obstacle is and
not doing anything about it
that's that's the one that kind of
drives me nuts and so i was like dude if
you literally spent one day and just
googled how to run a facebook ad
you would be able to run a facebook ad
by the end of the day like this is not a
quarter long solution like
do it you know what i mean and so i say
that to say a lot of people think they
are productive when
in fact they are busy and actually do
nothing
and i don't know if it's their fault or
whatever but
that is just an observation that i've
had and seeing the company become more
profitable
and grow even while we contracted
resources
is um sadly uh
reassuring or reaffirming and so it's
just like you probably know if you're in
a company of any size that like there's
like
a handful of people that you know that
everybody knows because those are the
people who move
right like they're people in our company
that i don't know who they are
and i don't know their names and i'm
like they're like oh we let go of
kelsey and i'm like who's kelsey and
then
now i've kind of been like well if i
don't know their name that's why they
got let go
because if you're doing something i will
hear about you they're like oh yeah this
new girl in blah blah is killing it
right i'll hear about it but if i'd
never hear your name it's because you're
not doing anything
so anywho that's uh that's another one
of the lessons i told you this would be
a longer one and uh probably more
encapsulated ah okay next one
oh my god data management is
has been the biggest mistake or
has been the has been the thing that i
messed up the most
in the last three years which is having
a
really good erp or crm that i run
everything dude is properly set up
and i this has plagued my business for
three and a half years and i think it's
actually been one of the things that has
kept us
at 30-ish you know a million a year
and we uh we just got hubspot
it's expensive i think we paid 36 000 a
year
for it um but it's worth every penny
it's just it's just worth every penny
it's it's so funny because we were like
man that's so expensive for crm i'm like
do you think that the entire system and
all the data of everything that you have
is worth more than a frontline employee
just one do you think it could provide
value to everyone in the company
disproportionately to one foreign
employee
well yeah it's like well like think you
know think in relative terms
um but now we finally are able to track
from click to close which has been
gosh the hardest thing in the world and
if i could start all over again so if
you are you know listening to this like
invest early in really good data systems
like it it will make your life so much
easier and
like i i genuinely conservatively can
say that we've we've left
30 probably 30 million on the table over
the last three and a half years because
of such poor
data management and because of our tit
systems have been literally the bane of
my existence
and so now when i start new things or i
talk to new companies
the first thing i'm looking at is where
are using track data what's your crm
you know are you on a google sheet you
know
zar is that how you're running
everything great let's
put the whole system in place so that's
just a huge one that
i feel like i now i got the i got the
success from that and i've learned from
three years of failures and so that was
a
a really big win for us um
next one is uh three businesses you know
i
i shouldn't have three businesses that's
uh continued to be a lesson of mine
uh because we have prestige labs jim
launch and allen
it's been very hard for me not from a
time perspective but from an attention
perspective to split my attention like
that
um and so i think part of it is this was
like a paired lesson in failure is that
i think the decision was incorrect but i
think that the lesson that i learned
from it was it
forced me to get out of ceo
and into investor owner role
and i think that was that was the gift
of the curse
the curse is that like i now know that i
shouldn't do that in the future and so
now i'm trying to
figure out really how to run these as
portfolio companies if that makes sense
so that's
that's been the hard part um and the
thing is you can't like undo something
like that you know what i mean i've got
i've got you know 100 employees like i
can't you know what i mean so
that's uh those are those are mistakes
that are
uh you know jeff bezos says when i'm
making a decision there's there's
reversible decisions and irreversible
decisions
starting a company is in some ways an
irreversible decision and so
um it's not completely irreversible but
it does you know
it it it's it's long and difficult you
know what i mean
if you want to try and undo that which
is either through a sale or you know
whatever
um or just winding it down
we're trying to like somehow sustain it
and systemizes so it stays at a certain
level and doesn't require attention is
also hard
and so anyways that's kind of actually a
lot of what i would say i struggled with
in 2020
um that i've you know actively been
putting solutions together for 2021 so
i'll let you know how that goes
um this is a big one know what your game
beyond the game is
this is a really big one that i've
learned in 2020 which is uh
you know we've you know my wife and i
have made a lot of money uh
over the last three and a half years we
took 35 36 million dollars out of the
business just in direct
distributions so that doesn't include
like the actual value of the companies
um and you have to know what to do with
the money and i
and i actively i'll tell you the thought
process i had behind this which was
uh my second year so in 2018 we took
home 17
4 in profit uh so that's two years ago
and while
at that point i said well if i were to
get 20
return on my money i would make 3.4
million dollars on the 17
right um
so me working on my business makes me
17 so i should just keep working my
business and ignore the money
um but at a certain point the kind of
the the lost compounding becomes
big enough that that it it can surpass
your regular income
and so you know if you look at what
twenty percent
of you know if if for example i had
actively managed it and
had thirty million dollars and done
twenty percent growth it'd be thirty
goes to thirty six
thirty six goes to forty two and at that
point you're making eight million
dollars a year
and that's two years three years later
right and so
at some point you have to the
opportunity cost of not managing the
money becomes bigger
um and so and it actually starts to take
attention like a lot of my attention was
getting drained
on the fact that just this gigantic big
stack of money that i was like what am i
going to do with this thing right i
don't want to learn the real estate game
i don't want to learn the
the you know hard money lending game i
don't like there's so many different
games for money
i don't want to learn the private equity
game so i spent probably 30
of my year this year on figuring out how
to allocate money
and i try to allocate them within our
companies because those are things i
have direct control over and i'll get
disproportionate returns on which is
you know candidly why i started prestige
labs is because i had all this money
from gem launch and i was like well
what's an ancillary business to what i
currently have that can provide value to
my customers that i can use the same
you know distribution based and shared
services on that i can make
you know that that i can get a
disproportionate return on and that's
what started prestige labs
and now you know two years or two and a
half years later prestige labs is a good
business
it's a it's a real it's a very good
business um it provides a lot of value
we paid over 10 million dollars in
commissions
um so that's been really good um
but it i i don't think it was the
correct decision at the time
but now that i have it um i am grateful
that we have it
so that's kind of the long and short of
that one um
but knowing your game beyond the game
because it will it will distract you
because what ends up happening is like
once you start getting into that world
you get sucked into it and then your
actual business
starts losing your attention that's
where your highest return on attention
is is inside of your business right is
your income
and growing it right because both your
net worth and the cash flow from your
business
both of them like it's one of the it's
one of the cool things about being an
entrepreneur is like the net worth that
you have in the equity of your business
is usually
larger than what you have pulled out of
your business actually most times it's
larger than when you pulled out your
business
and so um that's that's kind of you know
interesting
uh and so for me uh trying to figure out
how to allocate those things has been a
priority
so before i get the question i'll just
tell you this is this is what i have
uh invested my money in uh this year uh
first
we have uh a whole life insurance policy
high catch value up front you have to be
really careful about the people that you
work with this because they can totally
screw you
and they are incentivized to screw you
and most insurance agents will not want
to hear that but they
the the commission structure that they
have for these policies is insane
um it destroys the the cash value that
you earn from these things so
uh if you decide to set up a whole whole
value
whole vet cash value whatever uh
insurance policy uh one go with the big
four so that's uh guardian
new york life uh northwestern mutual and
uh
umass um or mass mutual excuse me
so those are the big four uh they've
been all around for over 100 years you
know new york life's been around for 183
years
uh they predate the tax code the reason
i did that
is because it it basically creates a
bank account for you that you can
use you obviously pay costs in the
beginning but you can basically loan
against the
the cash value of the insurance um and
the cash flow
guarantee is you know it's guaranteed
growth at about four percent a year
and so if you just compare that to a
traditional bank account where you're
losing money
um this at least uh covers for inflation
right
and so uh that allows you to at least
park the money in a way that's not
devaluing itself
and if you do see opportunities you can
loan against it and invest in those
things
so that's the first thing uh that we did
uh if you ever do one of those you
should be able to break even by year
three to five
at most if it's designed properly uh
they'll tell you that
no that's gonna it's gonna sacrifice the
long-term blah blah of the
of the thing i think that's horse [ __ ]
when you when you compare it to the
present-day cash
like the value of having your money
available to co-invest at the same time
is it's not even an argument in my
opinion uh it's also how
corporations and banks uh and fortune
500 companies structure it so ask
so look into coley and boli which is
corporate owned life insurance and bank
owned life insurance if you want to see
how they structure it because they know
what they're doing
and so that is how we structured it so
that's number one
number two uh we are investing in b and
c
class multi-family uh apartment units uh
syndication so that's
big apartment buildings um the reason
for that is because i think
uh i think single family might get hit
hard um in the next few years because
i'm looking at like
you know seven year timelines uh i
actually think that
i mean who knows i won't even make my
prediction because there's no point
but i think that that asset class has
outperformed other asset classes um and
if people downgrade
uh their living standards because of
some kind of recession because i'm
really much more about downside
mitigation than i am about getting the
upside
uh because my upside's in my business so
it's really like where can i park money
that i know it's not going to go
anywhere
and so i take inferior returns to know
that i have no downside or less downside
uh and so parking money in b and c class
real estate has been
one of those those places through
syndicated deals
um the third place is uh
i have index funds so that's
indexes of the entire market because
again this is one of those things that i
don't want to think about and i'm not
trying to stock pick
uh because this is not how i make income
like this is not this is the thing that
everyone is like man i could get better
yeah sure you get better returns if
you're a daily trader but you also have
a business
so are you going to learn that game and
be better than the biggest institutions
in the world that have
you know zillions of dollars to
literally destroy you
maybe but probably not and so what you
can do is be really good at your
business and provide good service and
private value and make more money that
way and then
be willing to take the non-premium
return
you know of active management and
basically make money on your
on yourself twice because you're making
money on income doing your thing and you
get passive
uh from your investments um i have a
five percent uh hedge uh in crypto
i don't really like speculative things
but the only reason i have that
is because uh if for some reason the
dollar gets devalued and for some reason
we lose the world currency
that would probably greatly appreciate
in value
and would the reason it's a hedge is
that i'm not trying to make money on it
i'm only saying that i'm putting five
percent there so that
if that happens that will probably 5x
if that were to occur which would offset
the losses i would have in basically the
majority of my investments and so
um that is my that is the conclusion of
my investment strategy
um and what i am focused on um outside
of just value creation in the business
because that's actually the fastest way
for me to increase
my net worth okay
uh next one if you are financially done
you must have a bigger purpose so that
was one that i learned this year is like
um you're like i mean i shared my
numbers transparently with everyone
um i we need to
um
like it you have to you have to sound
stupid you have to really like what
you're doing
um and have a purpose beyond it
otherwise
like the money starts being meaningless
and it like it just it doesn't
incrementally change my life
in any way you know like think think
about it like
i know this sounds crazy but just like
imagine if
buying a lamborghini for example was one
week's paycheck
well what do you do after you buy
lamborghini the next week right and
let's say you buy a crazy house and
that's like
five weeks of paycheck well then what do
you do with the other 40
you know five weeks of the year's
paycheck right like
it you know a steak dinner you know
like is is not that expensive in the
relative term of things like if i eat a
steak dinner
two times a day or you know went to the
capitol grill
and spent 200 at three meals a day even
right that's 200 000 a year um and that
is crazy for sure
but it's also like within the relative
scheme and this is where like
uh this is where the ultra wealth part
starts to get weird is that like
if you have 10 million dollars and you
grow by
15 that's a million and a half dollars a
year
and it gets bigger and that's what's we
like it's you can't eat it you can't
like i still eat chicken and rice like
it's not you know be like nothing
i eat bagels and i eat the the cheap
deli meat from
the supermarket like my life hasn't
really changed you know i have a
nicer camera now there's a thousand
dollar camera you know but
um you really have to find something
that
that i'll put it this way i have found
that i must do work that i find
meaningful
and that is what gives me purpose in
life um is that what i do
i find the pursuit of that endeavor
meaningful
um and the actual process itself
enjoyable
and so that is one of my my bigger
takeaways from 2020. laila and i spent
more time together this year
than we ever have and man it was um
the best thing about this year was my
marriage got a lot better not that it
was bad but it's just like we're just
really good and the whole year has been
great which was definitely offset by the
craziness of the of the world and i
think maybe that's
maybe that's why we came even closer
together um
but really focusing on the marriage has
just made my life more enjoyable
um even though we actually made less
profit this year than we did the last
two years
um and so yeah
that's that's that one um i did make one
good decision this year um
we actually developed a whole crm for
gyms for the same reason bringing up is
that you need to have good data
management
um and i spent a million bucks on this
thing
and i realized that i couldn't have
four businesses uh and so i pretty much
just killed the project and i just
wasted a million dollars
so uh i make lots of mistakes just so
you're aware uh lots and lots of
mistakes
um but that was a good that was a good
decision the starting it was not a good
decision but not doing the business
after i had made it uh was a good
decision
even with the sun cost which was hard um
another one is entrepreneurship comes in
cycles and seasons there are seasons of
heavy work and there are seasons of
there's seasons of reaping and seasons
of sowing and
i think recognizing that there are
cycles is really important um and
there's even
seasonal cycles which sounds crazy but
now this is like the fourth year
uh for our fifth year you know that
we're going into for us and
every year i'm always like i feel like
january through june i'm like we're on
fire
you know what i mean and then like by
december i'm like we suck and we
shouldn't be in business and we're
horrible you know what i mean and then
like january comes again and then
it's like everything explodes and so
i you know i've now i come to recognize
it and i prepare the team for it and i
think now that this is like my fourth or
fifth cycle through it
um i'm more steady and so that's been
um i think a lesson in seasonality i was
talking to brandon from weighty
uh wavy loss ladyboss uh weight loss and
he talked about the same thing is that
he he and i started around the same time
and he realized the same thing is like
doesn't matter what we do we are somehow
also subject to the cycles of
seasonality
and they always have their you know q1
is always your strongest quarter
why because people are more motivated in
weight loss when they're going into
summer going to spring and just started
you know just had valentine's day and
new year's eve so there's like all the
reasons are all right there um
you know once once it's august you know
or july it's not usually a huge
you know fitness month and you know a
lot of my business is correlated to
fitness
and weight loss so that was that one um
ah three year life cycle of products so
the average product or service has like
a three year life cycle
and um you know gym launch has had to
innovate it's i would say product suite
twice
uh so we started with kind of like the
whole six week challenge thing
um and then we transitioned to kind of
higher ticket hybrid bootcamp packages
and right now we actually sell the same
packages but the acquisition system is
different it's all outbound based
uh because that's actually where the
biggest arbitrage is right now meaning
we can buy
leads and get sales basically roi on
time is highest there and so we just
continue to see the cycle of
you know and you kind of get into these
transition points where like a new
opportunity opens as another one's
closing and then you kind of have to
like
readjust the product and jump and that's
always just focusing on like what's
working best right now
another one is having multiple
acquisition channels and streams is
really valuable
now that we have outbound you know like
i teach the gyms what i'm doing with my
own business
having outbound has been really nice uh
it's it's stable it's much more reliable
it's slower for sure
to grow it took 90 days to really get it
right for us
um it definitely doesn't take nearly as
i mean for gyms like we already have the
whole system but for us to start from
scratch and build the whole team and
figure out how to find the data because
like it's not just trying to find weight
loss like a lot of people are overweight
not a lot of people are gym owners so
there's you know it's different um it's
b2c versus b2b but
we had to figure out okay where do we
find the data how do we clean the data
how do we create these lists
you know what software do we use to cold
call what's the script what's the hook
what do we say on the opener how do we
train the team where do we recruit from
how do we compensate these people how do
we set up the sales process is it a
two-step or a three-step like
all those things are things that we had
to figure out from scratch um and it
took us about 90 days to figure it out
so but now that we have it it's actually
really great um
and it's just really cool having two
things that are really firing side by
side between inbound and outbound
um i wrote this one again but simple
scales
and so simple like really trying to
figure out
at all levels the simplest solution not
like
oftentimes the best solution is not the
best solution because it is more complex
and the simplest solution
though it might not be the best solution
becomes the best solution because
it is actually able to be realized and
so that is a lesson that i have learned
in 2020 more so than any year is like
we have made our product suites simpler
and more digestible and immediately
actionable and we're getting better
client results now
than even when there was like crazy
facebook arbitrage and that took time
you know what i mean to just learn that
because i would say like
a year and a half ago we had so much
stuff inside of our product that's like
it could be so perfectly customized the
thing is is that it was overwhelming for
the majority of clients
and so trying to to to rectify
the complexity versus simplicity
equation uh you know you kind of have to
find
the middle ground and the sweet spot for
what's going to serve the most people at
the highest level
and so that was just reinforced this
year and honestly right now we're doing
we're i'm i'm more proud of the jim
launch product now than i've ever been
which is pretty cool for me um another
one is that you can make
the right decisions and be wrong and you
can make the wrong decisions
and be right and so this is really hard
from a learning perspective
because let's say for example i bet my
life savings on
uh black at the at the at the casino
right
if it hits black was it the right
decision
probably not and so i may be rewarded
for
poor decision just like i could
make a strategic bet in business that
for all reasons
was the right call and then covet hits
right and then all of a sudden
that's not the that wasn't the quote
right bet but it was the right decision
given the information available and so
uh things change there are market
dynamics
and so i instead of beating myself up
over decisions i think
if all i had was the the decision-making
criteria that i had available to me at
the time the information available to me
at the time
was the decision that i made the best
decision and
what i don't want to do is unlearn good
habits right because we're constantly
you know evolving and growing as
entrepreneurs
and so not unlearning good habits
and and not reinforcing bad habits that
have good outcomes
uh is is is something that i have
focused on a lot this year and so
sometimes there are short-term trades
that have long-term
uh outcomes and i think this year was
actually much more of a long-term
focused
year for us ironically with all the
craziness that was going on
we put a lot of foundational stuff in
place that i think is really setting the
stage for 2021 so
pump for that and
i would say my there's there's more to
this but i'll i'll probably end on this
note
which is um
understanding an expanded time horizon
has been immeasurably valuable for me
and
this is one of those things where you
hear it all the time
right um but it doesn't become real for
you and
i feel like it became real for me this
year which was i'm independently wealthy
i don't need any more money for the rest
of my life if we grow our current net
worth at 10
a year we'll be worth 700 million
dollars half a billion dollars by the
time i'm 60.
and so that probably means i won't need
anything i could stop working now
right um and that
allows me to think from a slightly
different perspective
but the thing is is that i think the
reason that the rich get richer is
because it allows them to think from
this perspective and so the hardest
thing is
trying to get yourself into this and so
i'm making like this is if there's
anything that you listen to in this
entire video it is what i'm about to
tell you
if you can expand your time horizon
beyond months and even a year or two
you will be so much better off
if you expand your time horizon beyond
just a month
or a year and actually start thinking in
five year and ten year terms you'll be
so much better off
and i think there's there's so many
reasons for that
one is when you bet on long enough time
horizons you can virtually
get rid of risk and if you can make
risk fee risk-free guaranteed
upside then why would you not make those
bets
the reason warren buffett said this he
said no one wants to get rich slow
right but i would rather get rich for
sure than get rich fast and lose it
right or
or more realistically for many try and
get rich fast for my entire life
rather than just saying well if i just
did this for 10 years i'd be guaranteed
to be a millionaire
and i think that is the issue and i
think that's the problem that
the world has and that's why most people
will never become wealthy
is because they cannot delay their
impatience they cannot delay
their gratification and so
for me when i'm thinking about our
businesses i'm now really thinking like
do i think and this is because i've been
reading a lot about investor stuff and
i'm like
you know private equity firms will come
in and their goal will be to double a
company you know
uh in in five years right double a
company in five years
and i think about that with like gym
launch and there's so many times where
i'm like oh we got a double this year
why didn't we double
but if i'd said like we just got a
double in five
and made the plan for that the plan
would look so much different and also
so realistically attainable that i think
we'd probably
over perform that but what it would do
is eliminate
the needless frenetic energy of
of oh we got to do this now you know
like craziness of the shifts and the
turns
and like sure there's always things that
you have to adapt in the marketplace but
it just gives you this steadiness as a
leader
and when you can look at a five-year
goal but like i've never even believed
in five year goals
as a from a goal perspective but i think
of it in terms of a timeline perspective
of like
how am i measuring myself like when i
think about where i was five years ago
it's it's not it's like not even
comprehensible and so i mean i hope to
have that kind of difference five years
from now we'll see
but i think that if i can take a more
steady approach a more
disciplined approach to growth
and to value creation within the company
everything that i've read about you know
value-based investing um and how
you know companies do turnarounds which
is really valuable if you ever you know
want to get into a reading topic look at
uh you know by buying and buying and
flipping businesses
because you look at what they're looking
at in the business is what they can do
to improve and so you can basically come
in
with fresh eyes to your own business and
think like what would i do if i were
buying my business fresh from day one
today which is actually a really good
thought exercise and so i've kind of
walked through that process
and the things that i would do are
different than what i'm actually doing
and so by expanding it to an investor's
time horizon
i feel like i'm making much better
decisions and i have much better
perspective
and um it's been
it's just incredibly calming because i
think the reason that entrepreneurs
you know the double-edged sword of us is
that we're emotional people we you know
we
i get so excited and then we have all
these ideas and we want to do all of
them and the reality is that you can't
you just can't you can't even do you
can't even do most of them you can do
a very very very small percentage of
them and
when a private equity buyer for example
comes in to try and buy a business and
improve it
they will i'll tell you actually you
know i'll tell you what uh this
has been really enlightening for you so
i'll tell you what they do so the first
thing they do is to create a hundred day
plan
um and the objective that hundred day
plan is to align
uh the economic interest of the
management with
the fund who and the investor who's
buying it right and the way they do that
is they first figure out what their uh
primary
two to three kpis are going to be that's
it two to three
and then they figure out how to
accurately and meticulously track those
things so typically
you know uh investors are known for you
know cutting costs and increasing
profits that's like a standard thing
that they'll do
um but
they increase the cost on it and
reporting and diligence
and so for me thinking about that it's
like okay that just really shows
how important the data and reporting is
which is kind of what i was alluding to
earlier
and so they implement a lot of erps and
crm systems that they already have you
know test and whatnot
to get the tracking in real time around
their kpis now the number one kpi that
they track which i found
incredibly interesting which we don't
track which is wild
is excess cash flow and
it's crazy because that's the thing i
care the most about us as the owner is
what am i depositing my bank account
every month
but as financials become more
sophisticated you look at your profit
and your ebitda and like all the you
know your p l and you have to offset
revenue based on contract terms and blah
blah blah blah right
but all i care about is excess cash flow
and it was ironic to me that the most
sophisticated investors you know in the
world
some of them right uh the thing that
they care about is the thing that i care
about which is just
how much cash are you putting off you
know um and they have different reasons
for that because they can serve a step
better they can get better leverage
which means they can get better
multiples and blah blah blah and they
get better returns
um but for me thinking about that is
something that i'm going to be
reorganizing our business around which
is
how can we and and aligning the
incentive of the management team around
that
that kpi and so that's what they do in
their first hundred days
and then after that they only create two
to three
focused task forces right small teams
that can be held accountable to
um big domino operational objectives
that will provide the most value
in the the that have high probability of
success
they'll provide the most value to the
business and so that is it
and that's what they do and they just
ruthless ruthlessly manage around those
metrics
and i think about that and what that
means is they allow
the management and leadership team to
run the business
rather than metal and i think that i
definitely have a tendency to meddle
because i like doing things my way and i
want things to sound a certain way and
blah blah the same things all of us do
and um
and it's not it's not been it actually
hurts the business
and so um because it it removes
consistency
and so if we can create consistency of
operations it creates it creates
less waste right so you can be more
efficient
it creates a more consistent experience
for the customers
and so it allows us to make more profit
from less waste it gives
like i said more value um and it allows
us to just focus on a couple of things
without feeling the constant overwhelm
so i actually think that
our team etc itself would be happier
um with this type of approach and so
that is how i'm kind of shifting my
my perspective on our our businesses now
because we have three of them
um uh in doing that and so that's been
really cool um i've also
taken on a number of small companies
that i'm working with so companies that
are doing one to five million dollars a
year
that are either you know consulting
service uh knowledge education based
businesses
or uh niche brick and mortar businesses
um
that you know have have the desire to
like franchise or scale uh
nationally and so those are it's just
because that's that's the businesses
that i know
intimately um and so i'm actually
working with some companies there
um and that's crazy for me because if
you think about from an investor
standpoint
um i have a company that um i just
recently
became an advisor to and uh
they'd been at half a million dollars a
year for two years
i think um and now we're doing
uh 150 000 a week uh six months later
right so that's from 500 50 000 a month
to 600 000 a month right
wild uh so pretty pretty cool um very
exciting
um and uh i'm just i'm just pumped
pumped out the future i think 2021 is
going to be a good year
um i think there's a lot of cash on the
sidelines uh savings across the entire
united states
like went up a ton uh which means
they're printing money and people are
holding on to it which means that when
people start spending that money we
should see a boom overall
um i do think that you know as we have
an entirely democratic
uh president you know all three houses
or whatever
uh branches the government are all
democratic i don't think they're gonna
wanna
not look good and so i think that
they're gonna pump the economy as much
as they can
which will be good in the short term and
we'll see in the long term
as much as everyone's really worried
about the inflationary effects
which is definitely a concern there's
also really strong deflationary effects
going on right now too
uh so i also think that the people who
who are running monetary policy
are probably more knowledgeable than we
are it's literally what they do
uh for a living full time so
just something to consider there uh but
yeah that was uh 2020.
i have um i've i've i've had a
i hope you enjoyed this is different
than the normal types of podcasts that i
make this is kind of the
the top of mind the things that have
been most meaningful for me
um and i'm
i think i'm in the best mental place
i've ever been
which is cool for me i'm not a
particularly i would never have
described myself as a particularly happy
person um
but i'm i'm i'm pretty close to happy um
i don't really like the word very much
um
because i think it's it's really
misleading um but i'm i'm really i'm
really
i'm pretty fulfilled uh i really like
what i do
um i think i'm good at it so i find that
fulfilling i find it challenging
i love the game of entrepreneurship and
um i'm very grateful
to to be able to apply you know i really
am
and um i'm gonna leave you with one
thing uh
that i so i talked to my 18 year old
neighbor right and uh he's having a hard
time
uh he's got more stuff that's happened
since the last time uh you've heard a
podcast from me
just personal stuff and you know he's
he's having trouble with
the sacrifices that are required for
entrepreneurship you know he's young he
wants to have fun
and and and the thing is there's nothing
wrong with that
it's just the question is how bad do you
want what you claim to want
you know everybody wants a six-pack it's
just that they want donuts
more right they actually want donuts
they they claim to want a six-pack
but they want donuts more right and i
think that that you know analogy
is the same for business like he wants
to be an entrepreneur but
it's hard to see your friends partying
and having fun
and living you know their their youth
youthful lives without you
and it's easy to rationalize and say
like well i should enjoy my youth and
i'm not saying you shouldn't i'm really
not
um i just know that if you you know the
sooner you start
investing in skills and i'm not saying
he's gonna like investing in skills is
the thing right what he does to invest
in the skills is irrelevant but
investing in skills is how he gets there
and putting a disproportionate amount of
time towards developing those skills
will allow him to
you know outpace the competition being
you know everyone else right
and i said something that when i was 19
was a huge epiphany for me so
i'm just going to share it with you um
i was dating a girl for two years uh in
college
and uh she was very very obsessed with
happiness
it was like it was her major it was
positive psychology as her major and she
was really obsessed with happiness
and she ended up being
an amazing person you know what i mean
but i think
at the base um a relatively sad person
and um and i know that when we split up
and during that time because you know
people rub off on you i
i had become really really interested in
happiness how do i optimize for
happiness every
does this make me happy like all this
stuff and i think happy's a horrible
term
i think it's a horrible term i think it
poisons
so many people you know um and
i remember you know because you you're
kind of emotional when you're younger
and
uh probably we're emotional or older
which is better hiding it but
uh when we split up uh
she and i and i and i
had these habits of you know reading all
this positivity stuff and blah blah and
and i just remember going to this place
where i was just like
[ __ ] happiness i'm just gonna win
and that became my new kind of operating
standard i was like [ __ ] happiness
like i'm just gonna move i'm gonna take
so much action that i don't have to
think about it
i don't have to think i don't have to be
alone with my thoughts right i'm just
gonna keep
moving and i'm just gonna keep getting
better and i'm gonna keep making
progress i don't care if i'm happy
and a weird thing happened um
once i stopped obsessing about happiness
i actually think
that i became more content because
the thing is is i was constantly
measuring myself before that to this
what i would say you know what consider
an unrealistic expectation
of the human existence
and always finding myself deficient
and so the desire for happiness
creates an unfulfilled expectation
that makes me unhappy
and disregarding happiness
gives me permission to not give a [ __ ]
and if i happen to be happy or enjoy a
moment
or or find fulfillment in my work
then it becomes above my expectation
and so i have a positive experience and
so uh
one of the biggest things that i have
worked on and this is what i was talking
to my 18 year old neighbor about was
the only reason that you were upset
right now is because of a
fictitious expectation that you
arbitrarily made up in your mind that
you are not reaching that you made up
it's like if i said i wanted to gain 20
pounds of muscle in seven days and then
was upset that i didn't gain 20 pounds
of muscle in seven days because i worked
out hard
it's the same thing right i was like you
want to be a millionaire and you're
19. i was like do you feel like it's
reasonable that you think that after
two months of beginning your
entrepreneurial journey
that you don't earn above the top one
percent
in the united states like do you feel
like it's reasonable that after
eight weeks of not being in school
that you are not in the top one percent
he was like
when you say it like that and i was like
right but that's what you're thinking
you're thinking like that
right and so this kind of goes full
circle with what i was saying earlier
about having the extended time horizon
if we can extend our horizons then we
decrease
our own expectations and by doing so
we increase our fulfillment by default
because we expect less or nothing and
while we
increase our fulfillment during the
process we actually get better faster
and that was
what i have him having him focus on is
like why don't we say
what's a five-year goal that we believe
is reasonable
and let's make it action based all right
so instead of i want to make
four hundred thousand dollars a year in
five years why don't we say
what skills will i need to have that
would allow me to make four hundred
thousand dollars a year
and then what actions would i need to
take to acquire those skills that would
be reasonable
even with poor talent that i would
achieve that
and so for example we determined that
lead generation
and sales if he wants to be an
entrepreneur would be valuable skills
and so i said okay how do you think that
we can go about
guaranteeing virtually that you will
have those skills
and he's like well you know reps and i
was like right
so how do we get reps in and how many
reps do we feel like are reasonable
right i was like do you feel like if you
make 25 000 calls this year which is 100
calls a day
um it's just 500 calls times 52 weeks
right
you think you make 25 000 calls you'll
be you'll be able to prospect and get
business
he's like yeah i think after 25 000 that
would be reasonable like cool
great so that's one year next year what
do we do do you think after
if you took you know you know 20 20 high
ticket you know calls a week
over 52 weeks you know a thousand high
ticket
phone call closes you would be able to
be
at least proficient in sales he's like
yeah i think i could do that like okay
we still have three years left on this
on this timeline but i can tell you
right now if you can generate leads and
you can prospect for your own thing and
you can sell at high ticket amounts
you can make 400 000 a year no problem
but we're only two years in what else
we're going to need
he's like well i don't know what i'm
selling i'm like that's great so then we
have to develop a skill that's valuable
right and so at that point i was like
i'm not going to make that goal right
now we're going to develop these first
two
and then after that we're going to go
develop the other ones and so
um i hope these kind of anecdotes about
my my 18 year old
neighbor are useful for you um
it's really it's honestly been one of
the it's honestly been one of the most
rewarding things for me
um because i feel like i get to live i
can i can help someone
not you know suffer as much as i did
during that process and
really shortcut the the whole path to
success um
anyways i love you guys for listening um
this is
i you know i appreciate those of you who
find this valuable uh this is really
just
my mental diary for myself so that i can
look back you know
and maybe maybe hopefully you know in in
decades to come i'll i'll be among the
billionaire bros who donates their their
life
life's net worth to some meaningful
cause uh and they'll be like dude you
gotta listen to her mosey's old stuff
um and so hopefully that's what these
are so anyways
um i appreciate you all uh i'm focusing
on
simple i'm focusing on longer time
horizons i'm focusing on finding good
people
i'm focusing on getting them focused on
just a handful of things
and just driving those and doing
living a boring but steady
business life and
trying to come into it with no
expectations
and um and being pleasantly surprised
about anything that happens and so that
is that is my outlook
and i know that the world has been rough
my recommendation is to turn off all
media um it
i turned off i removed all the media
from my phone
uh because i thought it was especially
overwhelming and uh
i realized that my life was really the
same
without all of the news so uh
hopefully that's valuable for you and i
know that the news does not make me more
money
and i also know that the news does not
help me prepare for what is to come
independently because i think to myself
well what would i do differently than
i'm currently doing if these things were
to happen and the answer is nothing
which means it's not really providing me
value
and if it's like well i need to stay
informed if there's anything major i'll
find out
i don't need to go surf the news
to go do that so anyways 2021 i think
it's gonna be a good year for a lot of
us
um i think a lot of people grew a lot in
2020
and so as a result their businesses will
grow in 2021 like they personally grew i
personally grew more in 2020 than i did
in any other year
and i think that we're gonna we're gonna
i think the result of that is going to
show
um in 2021 so uh keeping amazing
and uh keeping awesome lots of love and
i will catch you guys in the next vid
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you